yeah okay doesn't for inviting me to
speak and thanks for putting together
this nice workshop right so I want to
talk about some recent drawing work with
some chief and this is about sort of an
attempt to sort of put forth the formal
framework for how one should think about
representation learning and whether it's
sort of benefits okay so let me kind of
give a quick overview of what I want to
do so I want to do three things sort of
in this talk I want to sort of motivate
and introduce this new framework that
sort of will allow us to think formulae
about representation learning then I
want to kind of clarify the framework
and make a little bit more concrete in
to kind of common settings so mixture
models and log-linear models and finally
I want to sort of show you ways in which
sort of having representations can be
powerful and the focus here I'll put is
sort of on kind of two things so one is
that they can decrease the need for like
sort of the amount of label data that
you need for some classification tasks
and the second one is they can sort of
help you do classifications in which
vanila methods like near sort of vanilla
nearest neighbors or sort of classifiers
in raw data space will require way too
much data so before we kind of do any
formal definitions let's kind of
intuitively sort of think what we want
out of our model and sort of I'll
preface this by saying that our approach
to kind of thinking about what the goal
of representation learning should be is
sort of motivated by sort of the variety
of uses and success stories that the
presentation when it has had and a non
exhaustive list here will be things like
unsupervised learning where we sort of
hope that representation learning is
tutor helping is discover some structure
and our data transfer learning which is
this sort of phenomenon that features
that we learn for one task seem to be
kind of relevant and useful for other
seemingly unrelated tasks and
semi-supervised learning in which we
sort of hope that if we kind of get some
magical nice representation it's
actually going to help us do
classification with a smaller number of
labeled samples and so what I mostly
focus on is the last point here though
are sort of our framework will be very
much informed by Bayesian types of
modeling considerations so you will
definitely get it though some sort of
sort of unsupervised learning okay
so intuitively what do we want out of
representations so typically we kind of
tend to think of a representation as a
relatively high level 16th description
of our objects whereas the raw
representation is kind of a low level
and is very detailed so sort of a little
bit of introspection will will sort of
lead us to the conclusion that this map
is sort of intuitively many-to-one so
when I'm going from raw data to
representations this should be
many-to-one
and for example let's look at the image
that I have here so I have like three
different pictures of a German
Shorthaired Pointer and you know he's
sort of in the like a few different
positions and you know intuitively we do
expect these to map to the same
representation or at least do something
the representations should be very very
close to each other
okay and so our proposal for how you
should model this is the following in
order to generate the possible fraud
inner manifestations of some particular
representation there's going to be some
probabilistic process which involves a
deterministic function G which eats up
the representation as one argument and
some extra random seeds okay and so now
if I look at the X I'm getting this way
this is a some kind of distribution over
possible raw data manifestations of some
representation age
so another kind of intuitive property
that we want is we want there to be some
kind of utility from passing to this
space of representations versus doing
things directly on raw data and sort of
a minimal thing that you could imagine
is that classification actually makes
sense and is easier in representation
space so at the minimum what you would
expect is that for whatever
classification task you're interested in
there actually is a classifier which
goes from representation space - let's
say distribution of our labels which
gives you a low error also we're going
to kind of need for our framework to
make sense we're gonna need it to be
sort of Lipschitz so what I mean by this
is if I view my classifier sort of
taking a particular representation and
sort of producing a distribution of our
labels I want this to be Lipschitz with
sort of respect to some appropriate norm
over the over the representations so
from these kind of two intuitive
considerations a natural definition pops
up so from the first kind of intuitive
consideration we know that our X's are
sort of produced as these sort of like
by applying this kind of deterministic
function to our H and some random seed
so one could think of the representation
is sort of inverting this map G in
sometimes if you will so that kind of
motivates the definition of what we call
the what we call an encoder and this is
kind of to keep in mind with a deep
learning nomenclature so we'll call a
function f a beta-gamma valid encoder if
with probability at least beta over the
XS that I'm producing via my
probabilistic process I'm producing
something which is close to 1 minus
gamma I guess they're close to the
correct representation H ok and in order
for this to you know in order for our
encoder to be good you want beta and
gamma to be close to one of course okay
and as a direct corollary of this
definition our second kind of intuitive
consideration which is that there is
some kind of sense in making in doing
classification in representation space
we basically get
from here that if instead of plugging in
the representation we plug in the output
of our encoder we'll also get something
basically a good classifier for whatever
task we're interested in yes so this is
definitely tied to a task so I'm saying
like if there is a basically you need to
have a good classifier for it to this
definition to be meaningful right if
there isn't a good classifier for a task
then you're kind of definition
definitely makes sense for every right
but so let me try to compare to some
kind of related notions here so
something that's very close to this is
manifold learning so in manifold
learning you will basically assume that
your points while being high dimensional
they implicitly lie close to or on some
low dimensional manifold and sort of the
problem with this approach is that
typically the way you learn this
manifold is that you sort of try to like
learn the local geometry of the manifold
and then kind of recover from that the
entire manifold and this eventually
boils down to some kind of epsilon that
type of argument so typically the sample
complexity will scale exponentially with
the dimension of the manifold in
contrast is that in our framework I'll
give you basically simple examples where
you can do with only polynomially many
samples in the dimension of the manifold
I mean of course our like our H is also
defined implicitly some kind of manifold
kernel learning is also sort of a
relatively related notion so in kernel
learning what you're doing is that you
don't
really want to sort of for some
particular classification task you think
that there is a good kernel which lies
in some family of kernels but you sort
of want to optimize over the kernels in
this family so in our particular case
some of the representations that we'll
be producing effectively look like a
linear map up like a linear map applied
to your to your audit and then applying
some threshold in right after and so
then this is kind of unclear whether
this corresponds to any kernel okay so
what I'm trying to do so the point I'm
trying to make is that our notion is
kind of different than these previous
things so finally this is kind of
clearly inspired and related to to to
Bayesian modeling and because I'm
basically assuming that you know
conditioned on the representations I
have some distribution over possible raw
data you could go full Bayesian and you
say there is also some prior
distribution over the HS and then you
are specifying a full kind of Joint
Distribution over both representations
and observables but then you sort of
might worry that our definition of an
encoder requires you to sort of produce
for an X like a single representation
whereas if you were Bayesian then you
would basically have a posterior
distribution over possible ages but in
fact this kind of this kind of like a
seeming friction can be easily resolved
and this is sort of a restatement of a
result that appeared in a paper to do
over a Koehler and ma that's effectively
if you have a good encoder this
basically implies that for a large
fraction of the XS the posterior on H
basically concentrates close to the
value that you're getting from the
encoder
all right so now what I want to do is I
want to basically give you kind of a
self-contained example where I want to
show you two things
so the first thing I want to show you is
that I mean okay it says some simple
like simple and natural setting and I
want to show you that encoders can be
efficiently learned both in terms of
sample complexity and runtime and
moreover they are useful for this sort
of semi-supervised learning kind of
scenario that we're interested in
meaning that if you try to do something
like classification or like nearest
neighbors directly in representation
space you will require sorry the
directly observable space you will
require way too many samples whereas if
you do it in representation space it
will require substantially smaller
number samples so the setting is pretty
simple it's recommendation systems and
it's fact in fact it's probably even
simpler than the recommendation sort of
a system studying that you're used to so
the setup is as follows you get to see a
bunch of users and then you get to see a
sort of a subset of the movies they like
so in this particular setting there
isn't sort of a numerical value of how
much you user like some movie it's just
basically he likes some subset of the
movies and doesn't like the rest of them
and you get to see some subset of the
ones that he or she likes and then you
could imagine that the task is something
like let's say for some user I asked for
some particular movie does the user like
the movie or not so we need to sort of
in order to talk about you know like
encoders and and and and their benefits
and stuff we need to basically we need
to impose some kind of liquid structure
okay and the easiest way to impose the
label structure would be a sort of
linear structure meaning a mixture model
so what that would mean in this case
would be the following you will
basically have the following kind of
layton structure and users in movies so
there are going to be a bunch of genres
and genres or subsets of movies let's
say subsets of n movies and a user will
be a mixture of genres so what does that
mean if I get to see let's say t movies
that the user likes the way I'm picking
these movies is as follows
three times I will repeat the following
procedure I will first pick one of the
genres in the mixture of the user
uniformly at random and then I'll pick
one of the movies in that genre
uniformly at random
of course you don't really have to pick
them uniformly at random you can pick
them with some mixing proportions let's
say you put them in some vector H and
you don't have to pick a movie from a
given runner uniformly random again you
can have some relative proportions of
omitting a particularly movie given that
it's from a particular genre and so then
when you put them as columns in some
matrix a you can sort of successfully
write the model as follows okay and just
to make sure we're all on the same page
the encoder in this case is supposed to
map the movies that a particular user
has liked to the latent genres H and the
semi-supervised sort of portion here
would be that you get to learn the
encoder first and then you can do
classification knowing these ages so now
the first portion which I promised was
that I these encoders can actually be
learned and so again this is sort of our
work is kind of done in this case it's
least in this linear case so if a
satisfies some relatively natural
properties having to do something with
something called the l1a1 condition
number it turns out that you can learn a
good encoder which in time which runs in
time and samples which runs polynomial
in the number of movies moreover this is
true when you when you get very sparse
data meaning that the number of movies
that you get to see per user is only
logarithmic in the total number of
movies okay so the last bit is very
important
no I mean you have concentration around
what the encoder is producing but there
is no sense of uniqueness I lost track
of what club would classic classifiers I
haven't I mean I haven't told you
exactly yet no I mean I think he's
asking whether we have a particular
classification task in mind so you can
think of just basically predicting
whether user likes a movie or not but I
think he's asking whether in something
concrete or just up to this point I mean
this is just about the existence of an
encoder right an encoder has nothing to
do with the particular classification
task right the definition is completely
free of that it's a corollary that if
you have a good encoder then you can do
sorry again here I mean I'm coming back
to what I said I mean this little that
you have no no no but you were asking
whether or not the in some sense there
is a unique way to reconstruct it or
something right you're trying to get
something close to the correct age right
you definitely have posterior
concentration right I mean there is some
concentration there is the in this a
security is going to be some posterior
right it does concentrate on some age oh
yeah almost done all right so finally
what we want to say is that we do get
some kind of we do some kind of we get
some power from these representations
and so now what to the way we quantify
that is as follows by looking into two
different phenomena so the first
phenomena is nearest neighbors so what
we can say is the following if the
number of movies you get to observe per
user is small let's say less than this
per M or something then the nearest
neighbor section will not reflect
blatant genres and I don't want to I
cannot I mean I don't have time to make
this completely for mo basically if you
look at the nearest neighbors that will
sort of not have any reasonable overlap
with the genre wise conversely if you
sort of but on the other hand you can
learn the encoder when you have even
just logarithmic number of observations
so this is sort of telling you that the
encoder is buying you something
conversely you know there's some good
news that if the number observation is
large then actually you know nearest
neighbors vole in fact work and
similarly we can do some we can sort of
exhibit a similar kind of separation
between what you can do with when you
know an encoder and you don't for a sort
of a just a regular classification
setting where you're getting a bunch of
samples along with labels and the labels
are just like you know look as a sign of
basically of inner product of some
weight vector and the plus minus version
of the latent vector right and basically
we sort of can exhibit similar results
first for things which are for log
linear models which have something to do
with
weddings and restrictions Boltzmann
machines but let me skip that and sort
of conclude
[Applause]
[Applause]